[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone i'm denny direct oh thanks for
coming to hang out with us here at ET
live season seven of Basketball Wives
returns tonight on vh1 and with the T
all the drama this season we got Shaunie
O'Neal and Evan lazada it's all good are
you doing you're comfy now but I know
once that episode airs tonight it does
give you a little a little tense under
the coat how you watch the show do you
guys kind of I mean I don't know why we
should be over it but I do I think like
once we get it going I totally am
comfortable with it's always like that
first night maybe first two weeks that
is just like like such a vulnerable
thing right you guys are keeping a real
real on this show you know and obviously
opening up your life to everybody so I'd
be watching like this you know right
especially you know what's to come we
don't yeah yeah and sometimes you want
like conversations with like dang I wish
they could have heard what I said right
after that or right before that you know
what I mean I bet that happens often not
often like yeah it's always interesting
because you get to see what everyone
else is see why you know what it is you
know we're filming a show we talk we say
things we gossip I mean it's just part
of the process it's like I can't look
away and I know you guys can't either by
the way we'll take your fan questions
just leave in the comments section well
again this is an iPad here but first
well let's start with the Mother's Day
how was your guys's Mother's Day mine
was good it was relaxing my boys were
with their dad and so with the girls
weekend your five heartbeats you said
yes
yes some say the boys were gone and the
girls were with me and we we just went
out I love that yeah my mother's day was
pretty good we went just for brunch with
Leo and and Shanice and um you know
halfway through brunch she's like I want
to go home so you know anything that's
plans always has to be you know
strategic we were actually gonna go to
Malibu but we ended up just saying um
sorta yeah local yeah I love that you
know this was their use but you
mentioned yes like mother like daughter
right there huh how much fun is that
modeling with your with your daughter
you know what she actually ended up she
they hired her for the job first and
then um I guess they were coming up with
this campaign for Mother's Day and they
were like hey what is your you know
would your mom be open to doing it and
it was actually really fun when it was
like two days and we actually ended up
doing that look and then we did also did
some workout stuff right so that was fun
and that was for a good American right
he's always lying yeah yeah keeping
she's a mother now herself Khloe
Kardashian
Khloe's a bit my topic a combo talk you
could recruit her for next season I'm
not some good TV like everybody has like
I was like you know you'd see us up I
just feel like it is you can't judge
anybody else a situation like you know
we've both experienced things that it
wasn't broadcasted the world didn't know
there were things that we stayed through
it was things that we pushed through
look past you know worked out between
the person that we were with and all
that you know it was several times so
this so happens this happens to be
broadcast it's whatever we didn't have
that problem you know what I mean a
little more private for you it was more
private Instagram wasn't a thing you
know Twitter was super new people warm
video and everybody's every move so like
things that we went through we're so in
our house
oh you know what I mean that it's
different now we were just saying like
anybody we date with go interested in
I'm never talking about it again keep my
nothing that does that affect your
relationships though it will going into
it like you come in with the wall up
when you're trying to you know get to
know somebody cuz it's kind of hard your
lives are out there you know you're like
I don't really mean anybody at the door
I love being home well I I just do I
love being home I love being home with
my son I go to sleep early but I'm up
early and you know he wakes up early so
um but I wouldn't say I have a guard up
I'm just I don't know I'm just I'm not
interested all the time yeah it's like
I'm a tough crowd I'm lying it does like
you know this is a couch of single
people right here I think you know what
I don't when i text you at 3:55 and you
want to take like 10 hours to text back
you know i want to be able to be cool
with you to a point where if i text you
back at 3:56 it's okay I'm not being
judged like I wide it why do I have to
be strategic well I don't want to play
this phone game I want to call you you
call me the night what it is maybe I'm a
little old school I don't but thank you
would you want to text is this too right
or you want to know that that person
might be thinking about you just say so
yeah we and I feel like we have our
phones in our hand all the time
especially kids no kids you just always
have your phone so there's no excuse my
thing is like you know what oh and don't
post something on social media and I
sent you a text messages oh my god we
saw I can't we saw you like that cut off
now because you missed me off no car be
gone party be one of her songs out that
new album so there she goes oh you're
not returning Texas but I see you like
in its room
we are connected it's like you can't
hide like you can get a call a text in
it don't say what a second read it out
totally you know there's a lot of women
out there watching who have who faced
the challenges of co-parenting in their
own lives and they get to do a privately
I mean what advice you have for them
like how do you guys get through it I'm
just starting my process this is a great
question because I feel like I always
say they have they heard in her extra
kill they do an amazing job of
co-parenting and that's something that I
look up to but I mean it was a process
it was not easy at first like a long
time at first just because he and I
would just not get along which then
trickled into like it's the kids missing
out on time and all that kind of stuff
it just it was kind of crazy but we are
definitely out of place and I always
tell everyone I was like okay you might
go through bumps and humps and all that
kind of stuff you have to figure out
what's good for you and figure out who
you are as two individual people and
respect each other's new lives and all
that kind of stuff and I never had a
problem with that but he kind of did do
you know what I mean so it was like
bumping heads but we're at a good place
now like very very good place like he is
constantly you know like she'll laugh
cuz he he only face times it's the
weirdest thing
it's like I'll just I don't know what
the face time is people always like to
face time now it's like the either text
or they face time yeah I'd rather focus
yeah but he face time so I could be
doing anything and it's I mean like what
if I'm on a date I don't want to face
time with you you like Shaq is face time
so then it's like yes I promise you
that's just a normal way of
communication
he's also nosey
he's not he's been asleep but just say I
don't I just say was a big turning point
for you and Shaq in that dynamic that
relationship oh where you guys are now
what was a turning point you know what I
don't I don't really know I think it was
when I was like listen it's okay that
you are dating and you have your life
and I'm dating and have mine it's like
you have to have some respect there you
know what I mean and I think that him
being a man and his ego and all that it
was like really hard for him I was I
wasn't dating someone for so long that
it became kind of like he could come see
the kids whenever he wanted he didn't
really have to give me much warning
things like that but then when you date
someone it's like okay you have our
respect you have to have some boundaries
and it was like wait what
so dad took right he took a minute to do
that but then once it happened it
happened and then like we could talk
like friends do you know what I mean
like I'll tease him about something I
see on the inside be like you gonna get
in trouble like your girl's going this
thing you know and we laugh about it
yeah so we just kind of just went over
that hump at some point but so what is
possible yes he is Friday I know him
well enough to like communicate with
that's like 18 what 19 years we know
each other so it's like I dunno he knows
I know when he's lying he's you know
just being nosy what he knows okay Chloe
you taking notes they all have them you
see them making it through though can
they get through that hump and stay
together and still have a healthy
relationship after all that drama
Chloe interest in I think you know I
think it's gonna be tough
I'm just talking about from experience
it's like you deal with certain
situations in a relationship and you try
to work at it but sometimes things it is
what it is you know I do know that she's
I mean she's gonna be a great mom and I
mean I'm glad that she you know was able
to have her baby and regardless of who
she ends up with you know
no I know I don't know you know I don't
know what I'm seeing is is that it's
like it's hard though when you do I have
dealt with things privately and it's
like crushed my soul so I can't imagine
dealing with those situations so public
what people never do I think they could
get past it
but it's gonna take work both of them
man I mean like she's I'm sure extremely
hurt but he's got to put in some work to
you know 100% maybe sit at home a little
more I don't know what come for them I
mean it would be nice to see them
prevail you know through this but he
it's gone yeah look you mentioned she is
putting the baby girl first though so
she's like happily have a child with my
ex and I was with him for 10 years going
through all types of craziness so then
you add a child into it it's it makes it
even more harder yeah to leave that
relationship because that is the father
of your child you know I do think that
maybe they should keep things a little
more private as far you know I know she
can do but so much bright do you know
what I mean other social media is I I
think she's trying to do I would
especially even after you know even if
things here from now they are in a you
know better place you know I just think
that sometimes your personal life and
especially your relationship is like
yeah I want them to fight for it but at
the same time I hope Chris let him have
it we have our first question from Alex
from Facebook he says he or she says
can't wait to watch tonight would either
you date another basketball player yeah
we have that question no I'm not you
know what I hate to say like oh just
because he's a basketball player I won't
date him but no why is that yeah I'm not
gonna say never because prior to meeting
Karl I said I will never date another F
we call and then I had a start so and
you never know I don't know you know it
even with the the three that I had it's
not like I said oh I want this I mean it
just happened yeah that's and it fell on
my lap and you know we met whatever and
had relationships long-term
relationships forty-three day marriages
I don't know I just I just I want to be
in a happy healthy relationship so and
of course he needs to have a job I'm not
saying yeah key from facebook wants to
know what qualities are you guys looking
for in a man
are you looking for in a man
well we definitely want somebody that's
honest right loyal I think those are on
the top of the right right good
personality I'm okay with blended
families so if you have kids I'm fine
with that like just like no crazy baby
mamas stuff I mean no because like Ted I
had several baby mamas and I got along
wow really did and some of them was
sometimes still like comment on my page
all DB so you know I was able to kind of
just so I'm okay with a with a blended
everybody like a good guy who fits in
but also you know challenges you a
little bit you have a little fun with
the mouth is sleek but I I have a as my
dad says like a smart smart mouth like
my my I don't like I do want a strong
man though like I need a man in my life
that'll be like okay that's enough
though or either I just feel like you
might be a punk I don't want take every
stone in your corner dealing with these
other cast members on Basketball Wives
you know I will say this whoever I date
I do not want him to even have an
opinion okay so anything pertaining to
the show that's just me per like stay in
your lane this is not your lawyer no
don't even watch it it's fine yeah why
do you feel that ways it cuz you see
this more I was like a work thing like
is it business or is it just because
this just really has nothing to do with
them
it just has me to do with them is very
its women and its little its caddy
things like you know if I want to go
home and maybe vent to you about
something then do that but then don't go
to social media and have a comment like
oh god I could act I have my own bag I
figured that out I don't like when it
comes to this for sure yeah yeah I'm not
I don't and then when I'm not doing this
I'm like you said if something happens
you've been but I don't want to sit up
and talk about basketball-wise with my
you know like pillow talk as you lived
it you lived in you're like I'm trying
to take a break from that we're gonna
live it we're gonna relive it right day
and for the yeah yeah we about that
we're not doing dating you will not see
who we're we're talking to none of that
today we have we have decided that
they're you know what you will never see
my man got to protect it is that a
little bit of privacy both right I
almost a picture with him I'm gonna have
like this big emoji face over him and
all you're gonna see is his body it'll
be it's him and his boyfriend and
literally every picture he puts like a
happy face like y'all are not about to
um you know but I feel like oh people
that lurk we'll find something else
right that looks like John private as
you can when it comes to the we're gonna
try well let's talk about these women in
your lives because if you guys have
watched the trailer for 77 I mean it we
expected now a Basketball Wives but it
is explosive there's a lot of drama guys
how would you describe this upcoming see
look at you you guys already you're like
we just talked about this we said joy
dropping cuz jaw dropping yes there were
definitely things that happen and we
were like in the sea as we were filming
it life yes you know okay
right why no Evelyn when you returned to
the show last season I mean it really
shook up the group and there was a lot
of tension between a couple of them I'm
thinking about Tammy I'm thinking about
Jackie Chris is asking were you with
wacky Jackie are you cool with her yet
you know what worried are actually in a
better place you will see the show no we
we are in a better place the viewers
will see what got me to this place
you know cuz I feel like you know
there's that saying when somebody shows
you who they are believe them and a lot
of that is happening on the show as
we're filming but yeah and we are in a
better place I keep saying we're not
running off to go get married but we'll
see what happens
Evelyn things they're not running off to
get married Jackie probably she likes to
give me or use your relationship with
Jackie's dad know what Jackie and I when
we saw each other for the first time
when we got you know back in this season
she said something to me immediately
about you know our pet because we hadn't
talked like we just didn't talk for
after the reunion and I knew knowing
Jackie in the history of Jackie she she
really is a lover like she really loves
really hard very passionate so when she
gets mad at you yes she gets mad and she
goes ham but at the end of the day she
really loves everybody and wants to be
everybody's friend so it was kind of I
knew it was gonna pass and I didn't take
I took her serious but not that serious
you know and I call it she got I
thinking I called Jackie crazy all the
time last year she was very hurt by me
call her crazy but she was just in that
place and they she was in a in a space
that never
in and she's definitely somewhere else
now so now when I call her crazy she I'm
like it's kooky crazy not like you know
crazy like you gonna be kill somebody
that's just Oh Jackie she's still Jackie
but she's definitely in a different
place now you know all that external
stuff especially the stuff that plays
out on on this show you know you forget
there might be something going on with
that person right yeah don't get out
there like we are still real people with
real emotions and although you get to
see a chopped-up version of a lot of
conversations you know there are still
feelings real feelings involved in a lot
of stuff and I just think you know
Jackie was going through some stuff that
had nothing to do with us that was
spilling over into what we were doing so
the way your guys relationship is now it
doesn't happen like that right away this
season right it's still kind of oh yeah
it's not a hundred percent it's not a
hundred percent but it's better but I
think is in the pudding down because we
got a little clip take a little for you
guys and you don't like her existence no
I do but do you ever feel like you want
amber were ever friends like really I am
okay not being
no I should be rolling it with a
demonstration showed up she is talking
about Tammy are in that cliff that was
like you're you doing Tammy like Evelyn
does full-on acts of the personation I'm
like more voice I imitate people I'll do
I'll talk like them she does the whole
thing the full act how's your
relationship with Tammy would you say
that's a big storyline that plays out
for you this season you and Tammy you
know I feel I I genuinely tried last
season Shawnee you know brought us
together and that was a genuine moment
for me of like okay let's like leave
this BS behind and move on because I
mean this is ongoing for so many years
but something happened at the Reunion
she said something at the Reunion that
wasn't true and I was just like I'm done
[Music]
quickly before we wrap things up let's
talk about the new cast members real
quick you guys have three new cast
members one returning how do they shake
up the group dynamic this season oh well
one those four really shakes up the
group in a way that's very surprising
that that might be the jaw-dropping part
that's the bar that's a huge bombshell
okay the other three you know
I think they'd be well okay Kristen
we love Kristen she's a sweetheart
Cece she kind of rubs a few people the
wrong way
yeah oh gee hasn't really had I think oh
gee did rub a few people the wrong way
and it is coming around yeah because
we're still going right guess CeCe's on
the show vh1's about to borrow this clip
I'm being honest she's yeah we don't see
Cece a lot we don't see Audrey a lot
either but do they make how quick are
those first impressions show up
immediately like immediately we just
feel like like hey they met og before I
did and they have so much to say I don't
like seeing her one time so much like so
much okay I think my reaction I can't my
my I could never play poker right I
don't have a poker face so I'm just I'm
just kind of like it was a lot it was a
lot of a lot she tends to do that have
to be like fix your face or what
Santee's are like six yeah
Jackie had said that new cast members on
the show they get a little hazed would
you agree with that happen do they get
hazed she said in her promo I don't
think anyone likes fish franchise like
oh like this is all the time thing I
think this is it she was saying like
they might get hazed you know I think
Kristin didn't get hazed for sure Cece
is hurt like Cece is Cece is her is
Kristin's father-in-law's girlfriend so
they already had a relationship
I think Cece just kind of got herself
into what was a joke and she took it
personal so then it kind of everything's
heightened - right
I was just playing you know what I mean
you know booze is involved a lot of
times too right well with that one she
just could not understand what white the
words we're gonna coming out of my mouth
over and over again though yeah and my
just plays out and even with like I have
to say with Evelyn and Tammy it's hard
with them too because if you're both of
their friends it's so hard because we
both know Tammy and Evelyn have like
these slickers Jabby ish like comments
towards whatever they'll do it in front
of each other also behind their back
each other's back you know another
conversation so it's like if you're
laughing they're both like I love Evelyn
to death and I love Tammy and so it's
like when I'm listening to both and
they're neither of them around I'm like
ooh she would not find this funny but it
is so funny you know what I mean like so
I try to put a disclaimer out there be
honest with both of them yeah without so
she was she joked and it was funny damn
it you know what you you're friends with
both of them and then you guys all have
to be in the same room more than one
occasion right yeah I have to let it let
him know hey hey yeah you know we're
having conversation for everybody to see
it's not like she could talk mess to me
and it stayed there it's going
everywhere
okay you guys tell it's gonna be juicy
this season you guys said jaw-dropping
right it's just a season where it just
it keeps we're still filming right
season that if things are just falling
in our laps cuz this times you have
seasons in like okay how is this gonna
be but this season even the producers
were like alright we may need a break
you start at this point you start
feeling a little dream yeah this is you
know in a real world if we were in film
in a show I would never see you again
but we are around each other wedding
best so you know and when I say in group
settings like night now where does space
where stuff keeps coming and where we
know we have a like we're gonna see
everybody walk in like right girl
it's gonna be on record groups the group
group settings are never fun I love that
you're like
even the crew the producers the camera
guys everyone needs a break
oh and we all deserve a pay you guys all
so emotionally invested in on the show
cause a lot of the crew they've been
with us for a long time so it's like
even though they're working so hard and
putting the show together you know they
care about us all right
they've watched our kids grow up like
they really haven't or like you look oh
let me feel like oh cameraman is just
like like he's taking the camera away
from his eye just like oh yeah I love
that
Wow I'm sure there's plenty of those
moments as you said you guys will watch
it all play out when Basketball Wives
returns tonight on vh1 ladies think so
much work that was good camera guys stay
strong that's right hey thanks for
watching you guys we'll see you next
time
[Music]